with studios eager to build as much hype
as possible before their films are
released March has been a fire sale
month for new movie trailers over the
course of the month we saw new trailers
for high-profile releases like infinity
war Deadpool 2 and fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald along with some
exciting first looks for upcoming films
like the Sicario sequel an action point
to name a few
with so many movies big and small on
their way to theaters in 2018 it's a lot
to go through here's a look at the
trailers released in March 2018 for
films that we're getting excited about
wildling from IFC midnight wildling is a
horror thriller about a young girl named
Anna whose thrust into the modern world
after spending her whole life being
raised by her father in the woods she's
put in the care of a police officer
played by Liv Tyler who soon realizes
that there's something strange about the
girl in particular Anna can't seem to
shake her fear of a local legend about a
ferocious beast called the wildling
there's a lot to take in from the
trailer which sort of hints that Anna
may be the mysterious wildling she ate
all the other children through the last
one left hopefully that isn't the
movie's main plot twist but even if it
turns out to be wildling at least looks
like an enjoyable ride wildling hits
theaters and video-on-demand services on
April 13th Avengers infinity war with
another full-length trailer for infinity
war released this March Marvel is
definitely cashing in on the hype set to
an emotional rendition of the original
Avengers theme the newest trailer hints
at a plan to make Thanos come to the
Avengers home field to secure his
Infinity stones and of course offers
more glimpses of the epic superhero team
ups we're all waiting for Tony Stark and
Peter Parker hashed out a plan with
Peter quill and Drax Captain America
hitches a ride with two chala Thor
brings the Lightning with rocket and
Groot it's like getting all the ice
cream flavors on one cone well -
whatever the Hawkeye flavor is very
berry look for Avengers infinity war on
April 27th terminal what is this movie
about the teaser gives nothing away
which is admittedly what teasers are
supposed to do most of the visuals
simply show a pair of feet in height
walking down a candlelit aisle margot
robbie headlines terminal and her
voiceover in the trailer hints at dark
happenings mike myers and simon pegg are
also slated to star in the film although
their roles are still just as much of a
mystery as the rest of terminal this
trains riding into the station on may
11th
deadpool - deadpool two's trailers have
all revealed something new and this one
sees deadpool putting together the
x-force team with plenty of action along
the way while the first trailer was
mostly filled with jokes about the
film's CG and writing this one touches
on the story a little more revealing
that cable is on a mission involving
Julian Denison's character and giving a
little more screen time to the new cast
of mutants at this point were all
definitely hyped for Deadpool second
coming on May 18th action point judging
by the trailer action point will lie
somewhere between a scripted film and a
jackass stunts showcase the film draws
from the real-life action park a
notorious New Jersey water park the park
featured such attractions as cannonball
loop a rickety waterslide that began
with a steep 45-degree drop and ended in
a bone-crunching full 360-degree loop
before ejecting patrons into a plastic
tarp being sprayed down by an employee
with a garden hose yeah it was that kind
of waterpark so it should be no surprise
that johnny Knoxville honed in on action
park is the subject for his newest movie
it's the perfect canvas for painful epic
stunts and with Jackass mainstays like
Chris Pontius along for the ride we're
just crossing our fingers that the movie
production suffers fewer casualties than
the park itself take the ride on June
1st tag go ahead and make all the
hawkeye jokes you want but you can't
deny the tag looks like a fun film the
story centers on five friends who have
spent most of the last thirty years
playing the same game of tag for one
month every year they engage in a
no-holds-barred game of you're it
ignoring all social conventions while
the game is on wedding ceremony funeral
for a father it doesn't matter as long
as they can get within tapping distance
of each other I think your dad would
have really want
yeah believe it or not tag is actually
based on a true story about a group of
friends who have been doing this exact
same thing for decades it's not all
light-hearted playground antics either
it was this film and not infinity war
that saw Renner break both of his arms
performing a stunt that's a little more
hardcore than getting together with the
old friends for a game of Yahtzee
the game begins on June 15th under the
silver lake from David Robert Mitchell
the guy who brought us 2015's it follows
under the Silver Lake is a surreal
neo-noir mystery comedy about a young
man in LA who starts searching for clues
about a woman's disappearance the deeper
he digs the more he begins to believe
that there's a secret code embedded in
the world's media with everything from
pop songs to cereal boxes hiding
messages for him to decode from the
looks of the trailer under the Silver
Lake will be a swan dive into paranoia
centered on a man who may have
discovered the world's biggest darkest
secret or he might just be crazy
either way the trailer promises plenty
of suspense violence and conspiracies
all wrapped up in a corset comedy under
the Silver Lake hits theaters on June
22nd Sicario day of the Soldado 2015
Sicario raked in huge amounts of
critical praise for its unflinching
portrayal of Mexico in the grip of a
cartel war although it wasn't exactly
the kind of movie that's screamed for a
sequel day of the Soldado will see Josh
Brolin and Benicio del Toro reprising
their roles from the first film their
job in Soldado is to push the mexican
cartels into a full-on war no matter who
gets caught in the crossfire denis
villeneuve who helmed the first film
won't be returning his director the
reins are instead going to Stefano
sollima an Italian director whose
previous credits include 2015 Subaru and
the TV series Gomorrah both of which
focused heavily on organized crime in
other words he should be a good match
for the Sicario brand and with a script
from Taylor Sheridan screenwriter of the
original Sicario day of the Soldado
ought to be just as powerful as its
predecessor look for it in theaters on
June 29th the house for the clock in its
walls as the director Eli Roth is best
known for movies like cabin fever hostel
and the green inferno
you know
the kind of stuff you'd take your kids
to so it may be surprising that Roth is
set to direct this upcoming children's
fantasy film the story centers on a
young boy who moves in with his uncle
who enlists the boy to help him find a
magical clock in the house that has the
power to bring about the end of the
world in the trailer we get our first
look at Jack Black as the uncle and Cate
Blanchett as the powerful witch who
lives next door from the looks of it the
house with the clock in its walls is
turning into a slightly creepier a
series of unfortunate events and with
Steven Spielberg's production company
Amblin entertainment behind the film it
should be a whole lot of fun look for it
on September 21st fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald Newt Scamander is
travelling to Paris in the latest
trailer for fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald where he apparently bumps
into a young handsome Albus Dumbledore
played by Jude Law
Dumbledore recruits commander to help
him put a stop to Grindelwald plans this
looks like the start of a magical
journey that will traverse the globe and
of course feature plenty of fantastic
beasts they both help and hinder our
heroes from new shots of Johnny Depp as
Grindelwald to several scenes inside
Hogwarts the trailer offers just enough
to give Potter files a thrill of
excitement fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald operates in two theaters
on November 16th thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]